[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be discussing a boku no hero fan
theory that Deku was actually born with
a quirk but that it was stolen while he
was still a child before he even
realized that he had it I have to stress
right away that this is a theory not a
spoiler this has not been confirmed in
the manga or anything like that
however there will be some manga
spoilers in this video
although season three of the anime will
cover all of the relevant material so
there won't be any spoilers beyond
season 3 content I first came across
this theory on reddit while I was doing
research for a totally different boku no
hero video so I definitely can't claim
credit for coming up with this idea and
I will link the initial post that I saw
in the description feel free to check
them out and the other day I asked you
guys to reply to me on Twitter and
Instagram with your own crazy theories
about the world of MHA and I will be
sharing some of those at the end of this
video for next time I want you guys to
reply on our Twitter or Instagram and
tell me who your favorite anime villains
are and why it can be MHA villains or
villains from any other anime or manga
just follow us on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar and give me your input
your responses will be relevant for a
future video and of course if you enjoy
this type of content and you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you new you can also subscribe
and Detroit smash that notification bell
so you can be notified every time a new
video is out now the key to this theory
that someone might have tampered with
decos quirk is dec whose doctor remember
back when deca was a kid he was waiting
for his crook to manifest but it never
did so his mom took him to the doctor to
see what's wrong the doctor examined him
and concluded that because he has two
joints on his pinky toe dec who is one
of those people who would never get a
quirk as this extra joint in the pinky
toe has become unnecessary for humans
those without it are considered to
represent the next stage of evolution
but Deku has to
so this apparently means that he will
never have a quirk and this is all well
and good until we realize something
incredibly important Dec whose doctor
from chapter 1 of the manga appears to
be the very same doctor who is seen
working with all-4-one the mastermind
behind the league of villains in chapter
59 of the manga once he appears in the
anime the doctor is even voiced by the
same voice actor on both occasions and
this is what has led fans to speculate
that the fact that this doctor treated
Deku and other young children is no
coincidence all for once quirk allows
him to steal the quirks of others and so
the theory states that the doctor must
have been using his position to find
quirks with lots of potential which all
for one would then proceed to steal and
so the theory goes that perhaps Deku was
indeed born with a quirk but the doctor
helped all-4-one steal it and simply
lied about Deku being quark lists the
fact that both of 'deck whose parents
have quirks makes it much less likely
for him to be born without a quirk from
a genetic perspective he would be far
more likely to be born without a quirk
if one or both of his parents were also
quark less so is it really possible the
deque who had a quirk but it was stolen
and this will become a major twist and
reveal later on in the story there are
two main issues with this first there is
the question of the second joint on deck
whose pinky toe if it is universally
true that having a second joint always
means being born without a quirk and
deck who does indeed have a second joint
then that ku was born reckless that's
all there is to it
but if it is possible for someone to be
born with a quirk and a second joint in
their pinkie toe may be a rare
occurrence but still possible or if the
doctor somehow switched the x-ray of
decos foot with someone else's to cover
up what he did then it is possible the
deku might have been born with a quirk
without realizing it the second question
is if deck who did have a quirk before
it was stolen how was he not aware of it
could occur
really manifest without the user even
realizing it well it all depends on the
nature of the quark and we know that all
four ones brother thought that he was
born quark less well into adulthood
until he realized that he had a quark
that was lying dormant inside his body a
quark that allowed him to transfer his
quark on to someone else and this quark
of course became one for all so with
that said if deku had been born with a
quark what type of quark could it have
been perhaps something that only
activates under extraordinary
circumstances like if dec whose life is
in danger
so if his life was never in direct
danger as a child dec who would not have
known that he had a quark at all and
shout-out to Felix on Twitter for having
this same exact thought let me know what
you guys think I definitely need your
help on this one tell me in the comments
what type of quark deck who could have
had so that he didn't even realize that
he had it and again I'm not saying that
this theory is confirmed to be true I am
just asking hypothetically because I
find this whole idea really really
interesting another aspect of this
theory is the idea that even if the
doctor didn't steal deku squirt he might
have stolen the quirks of other children
or even abducted children and turned
them into the monstrous nomal remember
this kid with wings who used to hang
around Baku go when deku and Baku were
kids
according to boku no hero extra material
this boy is actually the grandson of the
same doctor who told Deku that he was
quark less and now for the final twist
remember the winged Anoma that grabbed
Deku in the big showdown
during the stained arc well in the past
horikoshi has stated that there was a
reason why the winged nomu grabbed Deku
out of all the people there and the hint
that he gave us was this drawing the
drawing looks just like the boy from Dec
whose past and the strong implication is
that the winged boy from Dec whose
childhood the grandson of the doctor is
directly linked to the winged nomu and
perhaps he is even the winged to know mu
him
self if that is true that is really
really dark like Nina Tucker from Full
Metal Alchemist dark let me know if you
think that the doctor has been stealing
the quirks of children or even turning
children into nomal is the wing that no
mood the same boy with wings from deck
whose childhood that would just be crazy
and it would also mean that the doctor
turned his own grandson into a monster
if this was really true it would open up
a whole new dark chapter in the world of
boku no hero
at least that's what I think and let me
know if you guys agree down below and
now for some of your theories from
Twitter and Instagram
toothless gravy says this is a pretty
dark theory but what if the you a trader
is baraka since her family owns a
construction business all of the battles
between the heroes and villains could
provide the chance that her family could
get a contract to fix the damages after
all of the attacks well we do know that
Urraca became a hero in order to make
money so would she really go so far as
to help the villains for profit it would
certainly be a big twist but I don't
think that it's likely so far
Haruka as a character has been portrayed
as extremely nice and cute and dec whose
primary love interest so just from a
writing perspective I don't think that
this will happen unless horikoshi really
wants to mess with us both on Twitter
and Instagram I saw a lot of theories
about dec whose dad potentially being a
villain and that is why he is never
around but IG mommy xxxx Cece has
another idea he says I have the wackiest
theory about that who's that so it goes
like this it sounds crazy but just hear
me out
Dec whose dad is an ordinary man
mind blown Natsu fired up says that his
theory is that MHA is an alternate
timeline to the Marvel Universe each MHA
character is an alternate version of a
Marvel character like all might is the
alternate version of Captain America and
you can tell this by looking at his
costume and moveset well horikoshi was
definitely directly inspired by Marvel
Comics when he created boku no hero he
openly states this himself and he has
been a Marvel comics fan for his whole
life
so you can definitely say that in some
ways ma che is horikoshi zone version of
the Marvel Universe anime dude has a sad
theory that Dec who never actually
inherited all my power or became the
greatest hero but rather he was put into
a coma during the fight with the sludge
villain as he tried to save aku go back
in episode 2 and what we are watching is
his dream scenario that takes place
inside his head well if horikoshi ever
gets tired of writing the manga and
decides to give a big middle finger to
the entire fan base this is definitely
the way to go I can't even imagine the
reaction and backlash if this were to
happen
knocks tock who has a theory that the
dozens of fake accounts relating to
Minetta and Lord Twigg oh that keeps
spamming him on Twitter are actually my
own accounts I cannot confirm or deny
any of that at this time over on
Instagram we have shield labs and by the
way huge shout-out to shield labs for
making an awesome fan out of me and goes
and thanks a lot
shield lab says what if the UA trader is
someone who doesn't know that they are
the trader that would be quite a
misdirect for example a UA student who's
been under the power of someone with a
quirk of hypnosis something like the
mind-control quirk that he or she had
but long-term essentially something that
would force a student to report
information unwillingly and unknowingly
to the villains this is a very
interesting idea for sure and actually
my own theory that I talked about in our
who is the you a traitor video was
exactly that I said that nezhoda
principle may be being controlled by
all-4-one without realizing it if you
want to know why I think that I will
link that video in the description
obsidian Jade also had the idea that
that ku might have a quirk that wasn't
activated because /
it was suppressed again the idea that
Dec who may have had a quirk but it was
stolen or somehow suppressed would be a
huge twist and depending on how it's
done it could be pretty cool but again
there is no confirmation of anything
along these lines at this time abdullah
hal fauna also had the idea that dec
whose father's long business trips might
be related to helping the villains
because the idea that dec whose father
isn't in the story because he just isn't
relevant seems kind of off
why would dec whose own father play no
role in his life unless the father had
some sinister motives I do agree that
the father's absence is pretty strange
and horikoshi is really going to have to
dig deep to explain this one I'm looking
forward to finding out more about the
father in the future and Chris Alvarez
says what if one punch man takes place
in the same world as my hero academia
but in the past when being a hero for a
job was new to the world this is a crazy
idea for sure but I always thought that
the worlds of one punch man and boku no
hero are very similar to each other so
some sort of crossover would be super
cool I actually have a crazy theory
along these lines that I may make a
video about in the future just for fun
and that is all the comments that I can
get to in this video thank you all so
much for your input if you want to
participate in future videos be sure to
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more like it you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and Detroit smash that
notification bell as always thank you
all so much for watching thank you for
all your support and until next time see
our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]